so let me add to the complexity of the
situation we find ourselves in at the
same time that we're solving for climate
change we're going to be building cities
for three billion people that's a
doubling of the urban environment if we
don't get that right I'm not sure all
the climate solutions in the world will
save mankind because so much depends on
how we shape our cities not just
environmental impacts but our social
well-being our economic vitality our
sense of community and connectedness
fundamentally the way we shape cities is
a manifestation of the kind of humanity
we bring to bear and so getting it right
is I think the order of the day and to a
certain degree getting it right can help
us solve climate change because in the
end it's our behavior that seems to be
driving the problem the problem isn't
free-floating and it isn't just
ExxonMobil and oil companies it's us how
we live how we live there's a villain in
this story it's called sprawl and I'll
be upfront about that but it's not just
the kind of sprawl you think of or many
people think of as low-density
development out at the periphery of the
metropolitan area actually I think that
sprawl can happen anywhere at any
density the key attribute is that it
isolates people it segregates people
into economic enclaves and land use
enclaves it separates them from nature
it doesn't allow the cross fertilization
the interaction that make cities great
places and that make society thrive and
so the antidote to sprawl is really what
we all need to be thinking about
especially when we're taking on this
massive construction project so let me
take you through one exercise we did
this
developed a model for the state of
California so they could get on with
reducing carbon emissions we did a whole
series of of scenarios for how the state
could grow and this is just one overly
simplified one we mix different
development prototypes and said they're
going to carry us through the year 2050
10 million new crew in our state of
California and one would sprawl it's
just more the same shopping malls
subdivisions office parks the other one
was dominated by not everybody moving
the city but just compact development
what we used to think of as streetcar
suburbs walkable neighborhoods low-rise
but integrated mixed-use environments
and that and the results are astounding
they're astounding not just for the
scale of the difference of this one
shift in our city making habit but also
because each one represents a special
interest group a special interest group
that used to advocate for their concerns
one at a time they did not see that what
I call Co benefits of urban form and
that allows them to join with others so
land consumption environmentalists are
really concerned about this so our
farmers there's a whole range of people
and of course neighborhood groups that
one open space nearby the sprawl version
of California is almost doubles the
urban the physical footprint greenhouse
gas tremendous savings because in
California our biggest carbon emission
comes from cars and cities that don't
depend on cars as much obviously create
huge savings vehicle miles traveled
that's what I was just talking about
just reducing the average 10,000 miles
per household per year from some
somewhere in the mid 26,000 per
household has a huge impact not just on
air quality and carbon but also on the
household pocketbook it's very expensive
to drive that much
and as we've seen the middle class is
struggling to hold on health care you
know we were talking about how do you
fix it once we broke it clean the air
why not just stop polluting why not just
use our feet and bikes more and that's a
function of the kinds of cities that we
shave household costs 2008 was a mark in
time not of just financial industry
running amuck it was that we were trying
to sell too many of the wrong kind of
housing large lot single family distant
too expensive for the average
middle-class family to afford and quite
frankly not a good fit to their
lifestyle anymore but in order to move
inventory you can discount the financing
and get it sold I think that's a lot of
what happened reducing costs by ten
thousand dollars remember California the
median is fifty thousand this is a big
element that's just cars and utility
costs so the affordable housing
advocates who often sit off in their
silo separate from the environmentalist
separate from the politicians everybody
fighting with everyone it's now begin to
see common cause and I think the common
cause is what really brings about the
change Los Angeles as a result of these
efforts has now decided to transform
itself into a more transit oriented
environment as a matter of fact since
Ola they voted in four hundred billion
dollars of bonds for transit as opposed
to and zero dollars for new highways
what up transformation la becomes a city
of walkers in transit not a city of cars
how does it happen you take the least
desirable land the strip you add where
their space transit and then you infill
mixed-use development you satisfy new
housing demands and you make the
existing neighborhoods all around it
more complex more interesting more
walkable ok here's another kind of
sprawl China high-density sprawl what do
you think of as an oxymoron but the same
problems everything isolated in super
blocks and of course this amazing smog
that was
just spoken to 12% of GDP in China now
is spent on the health impacts of that
the history of course of Chinese cities
is robust it's like any other place
community was all about small local
shops and local services and walking
interacting with your neighbors may
sound utopian but it's not it's actually
what people really want the new super
blocks these are blocks that would have
5,000 units in them and they're dated as
well because nobody knows anybody else
and of course there isn't even a
sidewalk no ground floor shops a very
sterile environment I found this one
case here in one of the super blocks
where people had illicitly set up shops
in their garages so that they could have
that kind of local service economy that
the desire of people to get it right is
there we just have to get the planners
on board and the politicians all right
some more some technical planning stuff
Tron chain is a city of 30 million
people it's you know almost as big as
California this is a small growth area
they wanted us to test the alternative
to sprawl in several cities across China
this is for four and a half million
people what the takeaway from this image
is every one of those circles is a
walking radius around a transit station
massive investment in metro and BRT and
a distribution that allows everybody to
work within walking distance of that the
red area this is a blow-up all of a
sudden our principals called for green
space preserving the important
ecological features and then those other
streets in there are Auto free streets
so instead of bulldozing leveling the
site and building right up to the river
this green edge was something that
really wasn't normative in China until
these set of practices began
experimentation there the urban fabric
small blocks maybe 500 families per
block they know each other the street
perimeter has shops so there's local
desk
nations and the streets themselves
become smaller because there are more of
them very simple straightforward urban
design now here you have something
ideally love think of the logic if only
a third of the people have cars why do
we give a hundred percent of our streets
to cars what if we gave 70 percent of
the streets to car free to everybody
else so the transit could move well for
them so they could walk so they could
bike why not have Geographic equity in
our circulation system and quite frankly
cities would function better no matter
what they do no matter how many ring
roads they build in Beijing they just
can't overcome complete gridlock so this
is an auto free Street mixed-use along
the edge it has transit running down the
middle I'm happy to make that transit
autonomous vehicles but maybe I'll have
a chance to talk about that later
so there are seven principles that have
now been adopted by the highest levels
in the Chinese government and they're
moving to implement them and they're
simple and they are globally
I think universal principles one is to
preserve the natural environment the
history and the critical agriculture
second is mix mix use is popular but
when I say mix I mean mix incomes mix
age groups as well as mixed land-use
walk there's no great city that you
don't enjoy walking in you don't go
there the places you go on vacation
there places you can walk why not make
it everywhere bike is the most efficient
means of transportation we know China
has now adopted policies that put six
meters of bike lane on every street
they're serious about getting back to
their their biking history
complicated planner easier connect it's
a Street network that allows many routes
instead of singular routes and provides
many kinds of streets instead of just
one ride we have to invest more in
transit there's no silver bullet
autonomous vehicles are not going to
solve this for us as a matter act
they're going to generate more traffic
more VMT
than the alternative and focus we have a
hierarchy of the city based on transit
rather than the arm it the old armature
of freeways it's a it's a big paradigm
shift but those two things have to get
reconnected in ways that really shape
the structure of the city so I'm very
hopeful in California United States
China these changes are well accepted
I'm I'm hopeful for two reasons one is
most people get it they understand
intrinsically what a great city can and
should be and the second is that the
kind of analysis we can bring to bear
now allows people to connect the dots
allows people to shape political
coalition's that didn't exist in the
past that allows them to bring into
being the kinds of communities we all
need thank
okay
so okay autonomous driving self-driving
cars a lot of people here are very
excited about them what are your
concerns or issues about them well you
know I think there's almost too much
hype here first is everybody fits well
we're going to get rid of a lot of cars
what they don't say is you're going to
get a lot more vehicle miles you're
going to get a lot more cars moving on
streets they're going to this be more
congestion because because they're so
appealing to well driving or eating or
sleeping couple reasons
one is if they're privately owned people
will travel greater distances it will be
a new lease on life to sprawl if you can
work on your way to work you can live in
more remote locations it'll it'll
revitalize sprawl in a way that I'm
deeply frightened taxis about 50%
of the survey says that people won't
share them if they don't share them you
can end up with a 90% increase in
vehicle miles traveled if you share them
you're still at around 30% increase in
dmt sharing the meaning having multiple
people writing at once yes in my show
the uber share without it without a
steering wheel yeah the reality is the
efficiency of vehicles you know you can
do it with or without a steering wheel
it doesn't matter they claim that
they're the only ones that are going to
be efficient electric but that's not
true but the real bottom line is that
walking biking in transit are the way
cities and communities thrive and
putting people in their private bubbles
whether they have a steering wheel or
not is is the wrong direction and quite
frankly the image of a a V on its way to
McDonald's to pick up a pack without its
owner just being sent off on these kind
of random errands is really frightened
well thank you for that and I have to
say the images you showed of those
mixed-use streets really inspiring
really beautiful thank you of today
thank you
you
[Music]